has de estar pensando que el teorema del
valor medio es solo un teorema abstracto
que sólo aparece en clases de cálculo
pero veremos en este vídeo que ha sido
empleado al menos implícitamente para
darle a la gente a infraccionar a la
gente de ponerle multas por exceso de
velocidad y pensemos en un ejemplo
digamos digamos que estamos en una
caseta en una caseta de alguna autopista
digamos que esa caseta se encuentra en
este punto
y digamos que tú a la una de la tarde
digamos a la una de la tarde estás
llegando a esta caseta que se encuentra
en el punto a bueno puede que esta no
sea una caseta como tal sino de estos
puntos que por ejemplo si tú tienes una
una tarjeta digamos con un chip
inmediatamente te puede hacer el cobro
verdad cómo se puede utilizar en el en
los distribuidores viales o en algunos
en algunos puntos de la ciudad de mexico
por ejemplo entonces digamos que aquí en
este lugar donde tienen un sistema
computarizado registran que a la una de
la tarde tú llegas de ahí
y después de una hora es decir digamos a
las dos de la tarde llegas al segundo
punto be ok digamos que aquí llegaste a
las dos de la tarde ok y supongamos que
recorre este digamos del punto a al
punto b para fines prácticos vamos a
suponer que es digamos una autopista de
80 80 kilómetros que digamos que esto
tiene una longitud de 80 kilómetros muy
bien y también hay que suponer que el
límite de velocidad existe es decir hay
algún límite de velocidad y digamos que
es de 55 kilómetros 55 kilómetros por
hora muy bien ok quizás creo que sobre
la es muy bien entonces tenemos un
límite de velocidad de 55 kilómetros por
hora tu recorrido de 80 kilómetros en
una hora la pregunta es la siguiente
pueden las autoridades demostrar que
rebasa este
en algún momento el límite de velocidad
vamos a hacer una gráfica para ver cómo
podríamos resolver este problema
entonces tenemos aquí nuestro eje y ahí
tienen el eje y bueno ahora va a ser el
eje digamos ese ese de posición bueno
dijo yo sé que la s no es de posición
pero no quiero poner p porque ya ven que
en otros contextos la p es muy parecida
a cuando hablamos de densidad y no
quiero usar de distancia porque es lo
que usamos para derivadas y bueno aquí
en el eje horizontal vamos a poner t que
es el tiempo muy bien entonces el tiempo
está digamos medido en horas y la
distancia esta medida en kilómetros muy
bien kilómetros entonces en algún punto
digamos digamos que es en este punto
aquí digamos en este punto esta es
digamos la una de la tarde
en este otro punto
digamos aquí son las 2 de la tarde y
bueno claramente aquí no no estamos esté
haciendo una escala correcta así que voy
a hacer un poquito más explícito con
este con con esta con este sí bueno con
este digamos hueco que le pongo aquí
quiere decir que no estamos por supuesto
a la misma escala muy bien entonces a la
una de la tarde nosotros estamos en el
punto a déjenme déjenme ponerlo así
digamos que a la una de la tarde
estábamos en este lugar que
esencialmente corresponde a la función
es evaluado evaluada en uno ya las dos
de la tarde digamos estamos
en cierto punto
digamos aquí estamos aquí y en este
punto corresponde a la función s
evaluada en 2 muy bien esto corresponde
a s evaluada en 2 muy bien entonces el
teorema del valor medio nos puede ayudar
a resolver este problema de la forma
siguiente tomen la recta que conecta a
estos dos puntos
digamos esta recta
ahí tienen por su bueno imaginen más o
menos que es una recta que vamos a
corregirla un poco ok
ahí tienen esta recta que conecta a
estos dos puntos ahora qué es lo que
sabemos que como es la pendiente de esta
recta tendremos que el cambio en ese el
cambio en la distancia será igual será
igual a ese evaluada en 2
menos menos está en amarillo - s
evaluada en 1 muy bien y cuanto vale
esto esto esencialmente son 80
kilómetros verdad dijimos que al tiempo
a las 2 de la tarde
bueno la diferencia de distancia de las
dos de la tarde y una de la tarde fueron
de 80 km entonces esto es 80 km muy bien
ahora si dividimos entre el cambio en el
tiempo si dividimos entre el cambio en
el tiempo tendremos que empezamos bueno
terminamos a las 2 y empezamos en esta
carretera o este trayecto de este tramo
de carretera a la una de la tarde
entonces vamos a tener que dividir entre
una hora muy bien entonces esto de aquí
nos está calculando la pendiente de la
de esta recta que conecta estos dos
puntos así que la pendiente vemos cómo
podemos concluir es que la pendiente
vale 80 kilómetros por hora muy bien es
de 80 kilómetros por hora
entonces el teorema del valor medio nos
va a ayudar a resolver este problema
quizás aquí las autoridades usaron el
teorema del valor medio y bueno no no lo
sé a lo mejor es una posibilidad aunque
recuerdo haberlo haber leído algo al
respecto hace como 10 años pero bueno
digamos que por el teorema del valor
medio debiste haber llegado en algún
punto de vista haber alcanzado en algún
punto esta velocidad de 80 kilómetros
por hora porque primero observemos que
un carro cuando se va moviendo pues lo
hace de forma continua verdad no no es
como que como que haya una
teletransportación y de un punto aquí de
repente aparezcas más adelante así que
un carro empieza a moverse desde este
punto con una velocidad pues muy baja y
después empieza a hacerle el perdón a
acelerar acelerar acelerar acelerar y
bueno aquí por ejemplo tuvo que haber
ido frenando verdad entonces más o menos
una forma de por ejemplo conectar esto
es así muy bien entonces desde aquí uno
podría ver que definitivamente hay
puntos en donde la derivada o lo que
sería la velocidad instantánea coincide
con la pendiente de esta recta verdad
entonces usando el teorema del valor
medio podríamos concluir esto por
ejemplo
por ejemplo no se me imagino que este
punto más o menos ocurre que la
pendiente de la recta tangente en ese
punto coincide con la pendiente de
digamos de de esta línea que conecta
estos dos puntos y por ejemplo aquí
puede haber otra verdad entonces aquí
tenemos un valor c quizás quizás quizás
por aquí también tenemos un valor sé en
donde la derivada o que en este contexto
es la velocidad instantánea es igual al
cambio de velocidad promedio muy bien
entonces con esto podríamos argumentar
al menos muy a grosso modo que en efecto
el conductor sobrepasó el límite de
velocidad en este trayecto con esta con
esta situación hipotética